Germany's past and present were summed
up at this handshake between German
Foreign Minister frank-walter steinmeier
and hoja bull dodge a French world war
two veteran and former prisoner of war
he was one of several war survivors who
were present in Berlin at the
exhibition's opening steinmeyer spoke of
Germany's present-day responsibilities
deutschland de martes back then Germany
was a destructive force which is why it
must now work even harder to become a
constructive agent of order and peaceful
development was mere more than anyone
else it must fight for political
solutions to conflict and to sustainable
peaceful structures then and now that's
the theme of the exhibition at the
Historical Museum in Berlin it shows how
Germany and its neighbors have gone from
enemies to allies since the war what
does says making sure it stays this way
is up to all of us sonuva law securing
peace human rights children's rights and
women's rights is a never-ending fight
it's not a given say to zoo I compared
mano with conflict raging across the
world this message rings especially true
in 2015
Oh